but first another day another massive
crisis for The Reckless incompetent Joe
Biden and his administration America's
banking system and your money is now in
Peril this is a very real crisis there
are real fears tonight that this could
very well be just the beginning of a
massive Biden banking crisis with Biden
billionaire bailouts and worldwide
consequences two Banks now have
officially collapsed nearly two dozen
others they were forced to Halt trading
today amid Widespread Panic First
Republic Bank stock had plummeted a
whopping 60 percent of 100 billion
dollars was wiped out in one single day
at the very core of all of this banking
crisis is Joe Biden's record-setting
40-year plus high of inflation caused by
his multi-trillion dollar spending spree
and remember Biden inherited a very low
inflation rate of 1.4 percent and his
horrible economic horrible energy
policies drove inflation to one record
high after another after another all
40-year record highs and Biden inflation
has been anything but quote transitory
as they told us now this followed by
what 1700 percent increase in the rate
increases in terms of the fed the the
first financial institution to fail the
Silicon Valley Bank saw its massive
Holdings in U.S treasuries and mortgage
Securities quote hit hard by the fed's
aggressive interest rate hikes caused by
Biden inflation which Still Remains
uncomfortably High it is still not under
control but according to Joe Biden it's
not just his fault it's transitory
instead guess who he's blaming not hard
to figure out but take a look
during the Obama Biden Administration we
put in place tough requirements on banks
like Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank including the Dodd-Frank law to
make sure that the crisis we saw in 2008
would not happen again
unfortunately the last Administration
rolled back some of these requirements
okay first Joe Biden is lying if these
regulations were so effective he had
over two years to reinstate them with
the Democratic House and Senate no banks
by the way this large no Bank failed
under Donald Trump in reality multiple
Senate Democrats they voted to ease
these restrictions including Senator Tim
Kaine and John tester and Claire
mccaskill and many others even former
Congressman Barney Frank remember him
Dodd-Frank he lobbied in support of the
exact regulatory rollback as a board
member at Signature Bank which was the
second financial institution to collapse
today now the bill that was changed
that's right it was the Dodd-Frank bill
now in 2017 in an op-ed for CNBC let's
look at what Congressman Barney Frank
wrote quote there is one legislative
issue on which I am strongly supportive
of a change that will benefit signature
raising the 50 billion dollar asset
level at which a bank becomes subject to
the extra supervision so you got a
former Democratic Firebrand Barney Frank
co-authored the Dodd-Frank bill was
instrumental in removing the oversight
at a bank that has now collapsed that
he's on the board of and we're supposed
to believe this was Donald Trump's fault
now the bottom line is this it was Joe
Biden not Donald Trump that caused
inflation of spiral out of control and
that created the tenuous situation for
all banks in our economy it was Biden it
was not Trump who sat around and did
nothing as one expert after another was
warning about a looming disaster they
all lied they said no it's transitory
it's temporary it's not real don't worry
it'll go away in fact analysts at JP
Morgan they actually issued a warning
specifically about Silicon Valley Bank
in November of last year so how did JP
Morgan know while the Biden
Administration remained totally clueless
oh that's right the people who work in
the Biden White House are stupid and
incompetent but they're also political
maybe these are Silicon Valley friends
of theirs it will get interesting in the
days to come when we find out how much
money was donated by who and if anybody
involved in these bank failures uh in
fact donated big dollars to Democrats
instead of preventing crisis with expert
analysis and sound policies they always
blame Donald Trump they even blame him
for the they even blame him for the
Border crisis they caused they blame
Trump for what record-setting illegal
immigration no the Border was Secure
under Trump they blame Trump for Biden's
record-setting inflation no it was 1.4
percent When Donald Trump left office
they went all the way up to 9.1 percent
one 40-year high after another they even
blame Donald Trump for the war in
Ukraine Vladimir Putin didn't invade
Ukraine when Trump was President they
even tried to blame him for the toxic
train derailment in East Palestine in
Ohio even though Washington post was
forced to call out this blatant lie but
that's not going to stop them from
repeating the same lie over and over and
over again whatever happened to the buck
stops here if the dog bites the bee
stings and if you're feeling sad it is
all Donald Trump's fault according to
Joe Biden take a look
you take down regulations you you water
down regulations you weaken uh the power
of the administration to deal with
Freight railroad companies and then you
show up wanting to be a a great friend
of the people who have been impacted by
a rail disaster
Administration
there's a bit of a different tactic a
bit of a different approach and that's
probably why President Biden and not his
predecessor was able to Rally the world
and the global community and taking
steps against against Russia's
aggression
we were able to determine that China has
a high altitude balloon program for
intelligence collection that's connected
to the people's Liberation Army
it was operating during the previous
administration but they did not detect
it we detected
inherited a mess because of what the
last Administration did they inherited
weherited a mess and uh you know
republicans in Congress made it worse by
blocking comprehensive immigration
reform
by taking blame inflation no
because it was already there when I got
here man
come on man now when they're not passing
blame and shirking all responsibility
the White House is just flat out lying
and pretending that an obvious crisis is
not really a crisis at all they don't
have a crisis at the border the border
is secure we saw it in Afghanistan we
see it with inflation we saw with the
supply chain crisis and now we have the
Biden banking crisis is no different
take a look
Americans can have confidence that the
banking system is safe your deposits
will be there when you need them the
American banking system is really safe
and well capitalized it's resilient
and the head of the OMB said the same
thing sounds like they read the same
talking point memo now secure and
resilient okay two significant Banks won
the 16th largest in the country has
collapsed with two others now facing a
similar fate according to Jen saki the
situation is so urgent that Biden
started working at 9 00 a.m it was a big
day for Joey I'm sure he's asleep by now
he probably had his ice cream and went
to bed take a look
now it's important to note President
Biden does nothing at 9am he is a night
owl so the fact that he is doing this at
9am anyway speaks to how vital the White
House recognizes it is for him to have
his voice out there conveying that to
the American public
a night owl okay I'm not buying that
live for a minute at his early morning
presser well your President Joe claimed
there would be no Bank bailout and that
the taxpayers would not be on the hook
over the weekend treasury secretary
Janet Yellen said exactly something
similar take a look
during the financial crisis
there were
investors and owners of systemic large
banks that were bailed out and we're
certainly not looking and the reforms
that have been put in place means that
we're not going to do that again but we
are concerned about depositors and are
focused on trying to meet their needs
all right what changed Janet because 24
hours actually less than 24 hours later
the White House has completely bailed
out Silicon Valley Bank the
administration doesn't know uh what
they're doing and last week Janet Yellen
was in Ukraine for the past year now
she's been focused on a global minimum
tax Joe Biden has been checked out
pretty much from day one but now fear
not because every Tech startup Vineyard
and an Uber Rich celebrity with millions
of dollars that they banked at the
Silicon Valley Bank they will now be
reimbursed full and they say it's not
going to cost you a penny you will pay
every penny it will come from you the
American taxpayer that is their biggest
lie the taxpayers won't be bailing out
Biden's billionaire Banker buddies
because you will you will be now no word
if there will be any legal or financial
consequences for those in charge of svb
but the shareholders they're now suing
the CEO in the CFO for fraud now keep in
mind by the way that was a quick lawsuit
keep in mind this is a bank that had no
official Risk officer for eight months a
bank that just committed five billion
dollars to finance carbon neutral
operations a bank that paid out bonuses
only hours before the collapse on Friday
a bank that hosted an exclusive dinner
at an expensive Steakhouse uh the night
before they collapsed to celebrate South
by Southwest and a bank with Executives
that sold millions of dollars worth of
stock just two weeks prior to the
collapse coincidence or just good luck
or maybe not anyway now this Bank full
of Biden donors has been bailed out by
the Biden Administration really by you
the American people do you think that
you will receive similar treatment
American farmers are they getting this
kind of treatment are American ranchers
getting this type of treatment American
truckers getting this type of treatment
health care workers in our hospitals
with their vaccine mandates they getting
this kind of treatment no hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else